tu sais beaucoup de gens
euh remettent en question la loyauté des musulmans
vivant dans ce pays
c'est clair et simple une femme qui a un
foulard
tout de suite tu es pris pour cible
[Music] [
Music]
j'ai eu une expérience incroyable pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai déchiré sans
vouloir déchirer alors mes larmes sont venues avant
mon action de le sentir quand j'ai vu cet
avion percuter
et de comprendre
qu'ils le faisaient au nom d'une
religion
qui m'a choqué parce que la plupart de mes
amis étaient musulmans
[Musique]
ça a fait un  impact sur
la religion elle-même et tous ceux qui
pratiquent l'islam
c'est clair et simple une femme qui a un
foulard
tout de suite vous êtes ciblée c'est pourquoi
il est si important
de dire les histoires qui se sont produites
même d'hommes avec lesquels ils voient des hommes avec
leurs douches pour les vendredis  aller
prier ou leur longue barbe tout de suite, ils
sont ciblés, vous savez, rentrez chez vous comme
la première chose que parfois ils vous disent,
c'est de rentrer chez eux
quelle est la maison l'
Amérique a été ma maison
en ce moment 20 ans plus tard, vous savez que beaucoup de
gens remettent
en question la loyauté de  les musulmans vivant
dans ce pays,
mais une chose sur laquelle je veux insister,
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de musulmans
qui se sont
également mobilisés
pour aider de nombreuses manières.
et aussi un fier américain
[Music]
il y a un petit groupe de personnes
fermées d'esprit qui ne sont pas informées de ce qui
se passe mais je veux
dire que la majorité des gens
ici aux États-Unis sont
vous savez
accepter
qu'ils sont extrêmement généreux  comme vous pouvez
le voir,
nous sommes ici depuis tôt le matin et
vous avez des gens de différentes
origines raciales qui viennent ici pour
faire des dons pour les réfugiés afghans
[Musique]
j'ai ma vie ici j'ai mes enfants qui
grandissent avec moi
je ne le fais vraiment pas  Je n'ai
aucune
expérience de discrimination,
la vérité est que
tout le temps que je suis ici, j'ai
vraiment un soutien, même quand j'étais en
ville, je n'ai subi aucune mauvaise expérience ni aucune
discrimination. Tout ce qui était un soutien,
les gens nous aiment
[Musique]
à peu près comme si la discrimination pour notre
population augmentait
euh je n'ai pas senti que tout allait bien ouais il y a un
autre problème mais
complètement à part
la discrimination je suis musulman donc en
grandissant j'ai fait face à un peu de
discrimination mais j'ai l'impression que plus
je vieillis  et plus les gens sont
au courant de la situation, plus les gens
ont commencé à aimer
faire face à la discrimination,
mais cela dépend aussi de la ville
dans laquelle vous vous trouvez et de la ville dans laquelle vous vous trouvez
[Musique]
il est très important
d'éduquer les gens.
le fanatisme le racisme que tu es humain
comme moi
que tu saignes de la même couleur que je
saigne c'est ce que la religion t'enseigne
que tu es moi et je suis toi nous sommes
frères et sœurs
nous sommes ici
dans le même  terre nous sommes sur la même terre
nous vivons les mêmes choses vos
problèmes familiaux ne sont pas différents des miens
problèmes de famille n'étiquetez personne n'étiquetez pas
la personne assise à côté de vous parce
qu'elle porte une écharpe
ils ont une longue barbe
ou
parce qu'ils mangent différemment ou que
leur couleur de peau est différente,
vous ne savez pas d'où ils viennent ni
ce qu'ils font ni ce qu'ils ont dans le cœur
[Musique]